hey Steven what's up man what's going on
today's your lucky day I cleared out
your entire schedule because we're going
on a food adventure does this sound
familiar I don't think you have the
authority to clear my entire schedule oh
I do oh my gosh today's your lucky day I
spit out your entire schedule and we're
going on a good adventure Authority no I
did don't worry bring your bread let's
go first two episodes are worth it ever
were with Keith hammers burger episode
one sushi episode two burgers I was not
there so today we're doing sushi and
burgers in one Episode I just quickly
paid tribute to Keith Harris brighter
yeah sure Keith we love you
[Music]
[Applause]
all right let's go today on worth it
we're gonna be trying three burger and
sushi combinations to find out which one
is the most worth its price I think this
is a very interesting niche of
restaurants that offer both sushi and
burgers it exists it's a real thing I
love sushi obviously I love burgers
together here's the thing that'll sell
you on our last stop is a restaurant
operated by possibly the best sushi chef
in the United States he actually
invented a new way of cooking burgers
okay so now we're on a way to see Jun at
Kings burger and got sushi jizz actually
a sushi bar inside of a burger joint
he's going to show us some of his sushi
some of the burgers it's a thing I'm
telling you
sushi and burgers well it's in the title
potato and potato
no the little big guy same thing Oh
announce differently tomato and potato
[Music]
this was my dad's burger joint for 20
years but since fast-food chains coming
into this area he was having a hard time
you just thought to add sushi to your
fathers burger business I work for sushi
Roku katana a lot of people told me you
know you should close out the burger and
just do the sushi because that's what
you're good at they might believe as
long as you can present good food out no
matter what combination that is no
matter how funny that is definitely
it'll work we strictly use veralyn
salmon which is higher grade just a rice
and fish but it's a really good salmon
good rice and then that makes good
nigiri sushi and so when people come is
it typically one or the other oh
definitely both together that's the best
way to eat over here first they start
off with the sushi and then you know
burgers a dessert we just keep the basic
simple house-made Thousand Island with
the hand pick vegetable 7on CA B petit
certifying US beef lightly seasoned with
salt and pepper cheese it's a Korean
family an American classic and a
Japanese food it's the American dream
exactly Junior cheeseburger and salmon
agree I like it hot tea can you believe
we're getting this quality of sushi in
this diner in North Bridge Cheers Steven
oh you got smashed
mmm this is crazy good the sushi is
exactly what you want from a casual
sushi experience I think about sushi
stop as like one of the pioneers for
affordable sushi right I don't know
their job but yeah yeah they're writing
in the same way let's burger it up
isn't that a picture it's like I think
that grandma's say why don't you just a
picture it's off yeah pillowy let's bump
buns
you ever thought about having wasabi on
a burger Wow
in what universe does this happen
Northridge shooter alright this is gonna
blow my nose out but let's do it yeah
oh there's no reason why that was
happening it's like having a spicy
mustard on a sandwich this is nothing
weird happening here and now that I've
eaten half a cheeseburger I can have
some more sushi how do you want this
sushi you could soy sauce your burger
that's really good next we're gonna try
our famous king's burger and in the
kampachi three-way our king's burgers uh
cheeseburger with tons of pastrami on
top of the cheeseburger Wow yeah I can't
say more about that we serve three
pieces of kampachi and this is your
creation yeah I had a American cuisine
background and I wanted to add that into
the sushi cuz I thought that's the great
way to present my sushi in a special way
this looks like a dish I would get at a
home on cost a restaurant mm-hmm each
piece is seasoned ready to go you don't
have to do nothing okay the jalapeno one
hold pen use whoa there's buttery the
yuzu one is the one I want to try the
most
mm oh yeah right in a Sudeikis lemony
fresh little meal is coming to my mouth
last one is this smoke OH
hmm oh yeah they're completely different
preparation of the kampachi
and now the main course don't make sense
good food makes sense that's right good
food it will always be good sushi and
burgers are sitting in a tree you know
that phrase jack of all trades master of
none well apparently you can be jack of
two trades as master of both cuz that
was amazing you back there are two
popular dishes that can technically be
translated as hamburger in Japan what is
the beef patty in a bun which is called
unbag ah the other is a pan-fried beef
patty more closely resembling a Hamburg
steak and it's called Han ba goo this
version is often served with sauce and
steamed rice that is literally like a
sushi burner those two dishes are part
of that yo Shoku Japanese cuisine that
we learned about back in our eggs videos
wow that is both a fact a throwback and
vocab that's the double episode tree
throwing our way to our next restaurant
we're seeing Charles in court who run Oh
Toto a sock a bar which actually does
not serve sushi what they serve a burger
and a raw fish dish crudo may seem like
I'm cutting corners here but this is
actually the best representation of raw
fish and burgers next to each other on
the menu trust me the word of tototo
means little brother in Japanese it is
the little brother of our other
restaurant Tsubaki right next door where
does this cat come from I have to ask
I'm personally obsessed with cats I have
a little cat myself if the cat has no
connection to the name we wanted to make
it feel sort of casual and homey and
felt approachable and I think sometimes
that game
little intimidating we try to take some
of the mystery out of sake and make it
really fun and just get people drinking
it the characters Freeza kya literally
translate to stay sock a place the food
is kind of built to taste good with sake
and beer the idea is to have smaller
plates that compliment socket and all
the way at the end a heavy dish to sober
yeah we do some crudo which is raw fish
but not sushi typically in a nice okay
you're not eating sushi because the rice
takes up a lot of valuable space that
could be used for drinking drinking
right the fish is a tsunami which is a
flute it's mixed with black your which
is a Japanese shallot that we pickle
it's finished with usages and use the
oil lemon zest mix that together and
that's the fruit Oh what kind of socket
would you recommend with the crudo
because it is a raw fish we don't want
anything too strong right now my number
one pairing is Hakka a taqwa betsa gin
my from Yamaguchi in western Japan a lot
of nice minerality to it really fresh
Chris come on this coaster it's a little
cat face through your glass little cat
face Cheers
that's so wasting I'm stuck trying to
figure out what this is apples and
lemons lightly brushing against your
tongue Wow
trying to picture the scenario where you
are lightly brushing fruit against your
tongue and does not make me want to
drink so no I'll taste it whoa yeah
perform a surgery with these job thanks
very then in light I like that a lot you
know what I like about this visually it
kind of reminds me of potatoes happened
yeah okay I love it this is my kind of
dish this feels like something that I
could eat and drink even if I wasn't
hungry because it's just a little bowl
of flavor like chips yeah you just pop
it Oh
the little pickled shallot I just want
to buy a jar of that scoop it and you
know and pickles pickles are the best
when I die pickle me yeah you guys have
this burger yeah
the inspiration comes from Mossberg er
it's the second largest fast-food
franchise in Japan after McDonald's it's
huge
whoa it was a guy that lives in Los
Angeles you love Tommy's burger which is
famous for their chili cheese and you've
got the ideas of Japan it's a sweeter
chili more Tomatoes a little more keys
to the Japanese Alice
[Music]
better get some sake to go with that
this is a honjozo kimchi undiluted so
it's basically a cask strain sake a
little more power a little more alcohol
rich flavors and aromas look this is
burger oh that is good I've actually
never had a chili burger before this
moment what that's absurd it works yeah
it seems unnecessary I don't know you
need to go to the Midwest this is very
reminiscent of my cafeteria days just
it's good on everything this is a sick
combo so the chili is a very strong
taste this sake is standing up to it my
burger is gone I feel like I didn't say
anything about it
but that's how you know it's really good
when you shut up and eat next Food Show
shut up and eat that's Adams
iteration
[Music]
okay driver take us away got an e in the
cockpit hey how come you don't have some
gum and mints back here Annie yeah
what's the deal with so that does it for
Los Angeles we've sort of exhausted our
sushi burger restaurants you do realize
we've only actually technically been to
one it's a niche market Steven that's
what makes it good so now we're on our
way to New York City my favorite city in
the world New York baby we even made it
back to my hometown Big Apple Steve is
here he lives here for one year yeah
we're going to a restaurant that in some
ways inspired this whole video but
before we get to that burner back
[Music]
so the first hamburger wasn't even on a
bun look how far we've come now we've
got burgers and sushi when did they
start putting cheese on it
the cheeseburger likely dates back to
Rama
gotcha so the burger is a thing that has
always been evolving the next restaurant
next restaurant we're going to continues
that theme of innovation we're on our
way to Tetsu which is the casual
restaurant of famous sushi chef masa his
main restaurant here in New York City
around five hundred ninety five dollars
for a single seat we're going that cuz
we have to have a burger too you can
only get his burger that's it so what
kind of restaurant is tattoo pizza is
more of a casual Japanese dining which
is lots of a grill robata grill what is
that robota means actually that all the
way Japanese house every house has the
fire pit around called robot around the
fire not the way we do a long counter
facing to all the grill you know I've
heard so much about your main restaurant
I wonder if this restaurant was for you
a way to have a little more fun yeah
yeah yeah masa is more focused only the
sushi here is more kind of lots of
variety you know this is what I like
when I day off and I'm enjoying all the
different stuff
Oh interesting so this is more of the
day off style diner and it's a little
more accessible too right well yeah very
much
my Blizz is kind of 600 or start here is
you know burger $24 what's the one sushi
dish that we should have at Tetsu Paloma
well-known very famous one is we do just
you know finally scrape it they find a
capital C Reed and fatty tuna
but you feel like your burger is better
because of all your sushi experience
yeah but I love brewery yeah that's how
did you get interested in cooking
burgers seven years ago I started making
all about cast iron stuff - you started
working with I designing oh wow I'll
design the other location cast iron
popped I smoke cigar I saw that ashtray
was shaped like in a brutal so the idea
came from an ashtray ice - yes put
together like a shell it works the most
burger they cook in the flat planter
getting a thinner thinner thinner
right right Calais is intensive hub
create the crispiness between meat and
the fat the spikes are cooking it from
the inside as well through yes exact so
the masa burger that we're trying today
what comes on that beef with the
American cheddar so it's just bun patty
cheese that's it no veggies that's what
I like what Obama's special burner we
make him dancers very nice moist and cop
is crispy also we do grill same time
with Haddie what is the correlations
between making sushi making the burger
when you make sushi quickly this up key
quickly make sushi the best amount my
cast iron all those same things close up
they open it done after that we're gonna
smoke it with the good cedar chopsticks
oh why are you wash after customer use
so it's the old recycled charms are you
being used for the smoking that's very
cool
what beverage do you think we should
have with our aura roll and our burger
you know what what I like the normally
martini Oh
Bombay Sapphire martini from sorry then
I call gasoline you know everybody that
knows make us marks on the rocks
this is buy gasoline you came there part
of the masa and you can enjoy burger
part of a pizza we came to both Cheers
Stephen Cheers
season six finale whoa
so we're drinking martinis as Jeff masa
waited to dry olives on the side yes oh
I gotcha
mmm so we did not come in here planning
to get the foie gras nigiri
no chef suggested it so nigiri made over
at the sushi bar seared it with an iron
out of the grill that vile is crazy by
the way yeah this whole thing is crazy
that's true okay I'm just gonna use my
hands yours too vendors
Wow that is insane whoa the foie gras
just instantly disappeared in my mouth
it was basically just a ball of rice
saturated with a lot of fat speaking of
fat okay fatty tuna oh oh yeah easily
the best roll I've ever had
yeah normally a sushi roll it still
feels like a cylinder in your mouth this
disappears into a cloud of sushi I'm
gonna do a little bit less awesome tuna
is my favorite fish oral cuz your bougie
that's what tuna is not bougie Oh your
sister have you seen a tuna Adam you
want some Oh give me a descriptor okay
okay now we're gonna throw some gasoline
on the fire mm-hmm eat a burger here
Steven Cheers
did chef masa make these dishes he did
made these kids a guy get any cooler
the smell is ridiculous
oh well you know the most blood miss
I've ever felt in my entire life
look at that smoke coming out this is
sinful taking a bite of this thing you
don't desire any sauce or condiments or
anything it's just good on its own on
the way here I was super nervous we're
gonna be like chef masa and then we walk
in and the guys in the hoodie I totally
forgot that I was nervous about any of
this right I think it's true of all the
best food its disarming you immediately
forget that you're anywhere except
somewhere eating delicious foods that
was exactly what I wanted and I'm cool
you are a fool cool Oh Mary we go on our
way I take the gasoline away No all
right okay have you ever seen a burger
prepared that way before I've never seen
any other food prepared that way he's an
actual medieval Iron Maiden to cook a
cheeseburger well well Andrew which
sushi and burger spot was most worth it
to you at his given price my worth it
winner is got sushi and Kings burger no
way you could go in for just one or the
other be totally satisfied or you get
both and have the best time of your life
my or the winner goes to Tetsu whoa with
anybody surprised though no you're a
fancy boy no I'm not a fancy boy we just
ate at a restaurant with one of the most
esteemed sushi chefs in the world but
ours wanted to eat the burger to Adam
that is totally fair in this episode at
one time I will let you see Annie who's
your whirter winner season six that's a
wrap I just want to say thank you to
everybody who makes this show possible
all you see is the head of this stink
and the unhinged jaw that devours all
the food and it's bad much like an
anaconda do we have an edit team a
production team get a legal team we have
a research team all the teams that must
be thank you to all the people we really
can do without y'all
[Music]